Hey, hey, I'm not hearing any better ideas from you. I'm on three hours of sleep here. I've been up since I don't even remember when. Oh, yeah, I almost died on the plane, too. That was crazy. That was crazy. You almost died on the plane? Yeah, yeah.
嘿，嘿，我没听到你有什么更好的主意。我只睡了三个小时。我不知道从什么时候起就一直醒着。哦，对了，我在飞机上还差点死了。那太疯狂了。那太疯狂了。你在飞机上差点死了？是啊，是啊。
Would you like to elaborate? Yeah, I would like to elaborate. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 188 recorded on June 11th 2024. My name is Connor and today with my co host Bryce, we chat about how to implement a parallel merge. Moving on to episode 188. What are we talking about? I got a topic. Perfect. Saved our listeners from me just rambling.
你想详细说明一下吗？是的，我想详细说明一下。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 188 期，录制于 2024 年 6 月 11 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，我们来聊聊如何实现并行归并。进入第 188 期。我们要聊什么？我有个话题。太棒了。拯救了我们的听众，不用听我胡言乱语了。
Both of us are just super ill-prepared to this but uh so how does parallel merge work how does okay let's take a step back how does how does serial merge work serial merge of just two lists yeah yeah yeah mean, that's trivial, no? I wouldn't be asking if it was. I mean, if you've got two separate lists and you're merging into a new list, then that is the easiest case, right? You just got two pointers into each array and you're just doing a comparison each time and while you have the lower value you copy that into the new list and move the iterator and repeat rinse repeat okay in a case where you are trying to do it quote unquote in place which doesn't really exist for merge but you're going to end up doing a bunch of insertions, which is probably going to be worse.
我们俩对这一期都准备得非常不足，但是，嗯，并行归并是怎么工作的？好吧，让我们退一步，串行归并是怎么工作的？两个列表的串行归并，是啊，是啊，我的意思是，那很简单，不是吗？如果很简单我就不会问了。我的意思是，如果你有两个独立的列表，并且你要把它们合并到一个新列表中，那是最简单的情况，对吧？你只需要在每个数组中各有一个指针，每次进行一次比较，当你得到较小的值时，就把它复制到新列表中，移动迭代器，然后重复这个过程。好吧，如果你想尝试所谓的“原地”合并，这对于归并来说并不真正存在，但你最终会进行大量的插入操作，这可能会更糟。
It's going to be way worse for time complexity. Actually, is it? Interesting, yeah. So if you want to do an in-place merge where you've got list A and list B and you're going to resize list A to be the sum of both your sizes, is that worse time complexity? So the first one is linear in the length of both of your lists.
在时间复杂度上会糟糕得多。真的吗？有意思，是啊。所以如果你想做一个原地归并，你有列表 A 和列表 B，你要把列表 A 的大小调整为两者之和，那样时间复杂度会更糟吗？所以第一个是关于两个列表长度的线性时间。
The second one, I mean, technically, couldn't you do something where you fill it from the back and then you don't need to do a bunch of insertions? Yeah, that's brilliant. Brilliant, folks. That's what you do. So instead of... But it's still linear. It's still linear.
第二个，我的意思是，从技术上讲，你不能从后面填充，这样就不需要进行大量的插入了吗？是的，那太聪明了。太聪明了，伙计们。这就是你要做的。所以与其……但它仍然是线性的。它仍然是线性的。
But I was imagining if you're filling it from the front each time you want to insert an element from b into some middle position of a you're going to end up you know having to reallocate or actually you won't have to reallocate but you're gonna have to do these copies of like n elements at a time or you know some linear number of elements at a time every time you do an insertion from B. But if you do it backwards, you're just basically doing the exact same algorithm. You just have pointers at the end, and you don't need to worry about doing that linear copies of elements. All right, so we...
但我设想的是，如果你每次都从前面填充，当你想要把 B 中的一个元素插入到 A 的某个中间位置时，你最终会不得不重新分配，或者实际上你不需要重新分配，但你必须进行这些每次 n 个元素的复制，或者说每次你从 B 进行插入时，都要进行某种线性数量的元素复制。但如果你从后面做，你基本上是在做完全相同的算法。你只需要在末尾有指针，就不需要担心进行那些元素的线性复制了。好吧，所以我们……
Does this get worse if you want to merge K lists, not two lists? No. Do you have to do more comparisons? Yeah, you have to do more comparisons, but that's fine. Doesn't that... Or does does it i think it might so it so at any given you know i'm i'm do i i've got k lists of length m and uh at any and i so i'm going to iterate M times. And for each one of those M iterations, I have to... I guess it's true, yeah. It becomes K times M.
如果你想合并 K 个列表，而不是两个列表，这会变得更糟吗？不会。你必须进行更多的比较吗？是的，你必须进行更多的比较，但这没关系。那不会……或者说，我觉得可能会，所以，在任何给定的……我有 K 个长度为 M 的列表，并且……我将迭代 M 次。对于那 M 次迭代中的每一次，我必须……我想这是真的，是的。它变成了 K 乘以 M。
I have to do like... Well, no, don't I have to do like log K comparisons? Why log K? Well, because I've got like k things I need to find the smallest, right? Mm-hmm. So can't I just do like a min heap?
我必须做类似……嗯，不，我难道不需要做类似 log K 次比较吗？为什么是 log K？嗯，因为我有 K 个东西需要找到最小的，对吧？嗯。所以我不能只做一个最小堆吗？
But your values across your k lists are not in a min heap. You just have pointers to whatever value you're at. Right, right. But I'm saying, like, I got k things.
但你 K 个列表中的值并不在一个最小堆中。你只是有指向你当前所在值的指针。对，对。但我的意思是，我有 K 个东西。
I got to find the smallest one. In order to do a log n lookup on k elements, they have to be in a structure that you can do a log k lookup on them. And they're just in some array, so it's just going to be linear. Yeah, yeah. Okay, so maybe for the k list it is actually
我得找到最小的一个。为了在 K 个元素上进行 log n 的查找，它们必须处于一种你可以对其进行 log k 查找的结构中。而它们只是在某个数组中，所以它只会是线性的。是啊，是啊。好吧，所以也许对于 K 个列表，它实际上是
k times n but the the algorithm is still morally the same all right i did linear you can do parallel well i know i know that uh you know this is a building block of our of our parallel merge sort i don't i don't actually know how it works. We use this thing called the parallel merge path algorithm, I think. Let's see if I can understand how this works. I actually have no clue. Do you have any intuition? Maybe we should limit ourselves to the two-list case to think about this.
K 乘以 N，但算法在本质上仍然是一样的。好吧，我做了线性的，你可以做并行的。嗯，我知道，我知道……你知道，这是我们并行归并排序的一个构建块。我其实不知道它是怎么工作的。我想我们用的是一种叫并行归并路径算法的东西。看看我能不能理解它是怎么工作的。我其实一点头绪都没有。你有什么直觉吗？也许我们应该把自己限制在两个列表的情况下来思考这个问题。
Well, how would I... My approach to solving this, not knowing off the top of my head, is how would I implement this in terms of thrust algorithms? And you would do this with a copy if algorithm, and could you do it with some kind of scatter iterator or gather iterator if you did some kind of... I mean, they're already sorted, so... Right, they're already sorted. But there's got to be some kind of thing where you do some...
嗯，我会怎么……我解决这个问题的方法，在不知道具体细节的情况下，是如何用 Thrust 算法来实现它？你会用 copy_if 算法来做，如果你用某种散列迭代器或聚集迭代器，你能做到吗？我的意思是，它们已经是排序过的了，所以……对，它们已经是排序过的了。但肯定有某种东西，你可以做一些……
Okay, well, hang on. Let's start with the dumbest way you could do this, right? The dumbest way would be like you just do some sort of segmented sort, right? Like you just re-sort the entire thing in parallel. We know how to sort in parallel. I mean, that's not a merge, though. I mean, okay, yeah, sure. If you want to do the dumbest thing possible,
好吧，等等。让我们从你能做的最笨的方法开始，对吧？最笨的方法就像是你做某种分段排序，对吧？就像你只是并行地重新排序整个东西。我们知道如何并行排序。我的意思是，那不是归并，不过。我的意思是，好吧，是的，当然。如果你想做最笨的事情，
create a new list and just sort it. But that is, I feel like you haven't answered the question. I mean, technically, if you're in an interview and someone says implement a parallel merge, and then you write the function body merge, and then you just do a copy if to the back of the first vector after resizing, and then you call thrust sort i mean technically you did implement a parallel merge not exactly i think what the interviewer would have been asking for but you know sure sure but what i'm saying is it's only uphill from here i mean if we want to if you want to say that i mean you probably could choose something worse
创建一个新列表然后直接排序。但我觉得你没有回答这个问题。我的意思是，从技术上讲，如果你在面试中，有人说实现一个并行归并，然后你写了函数体 merge，然后你在调整大小后对第一个向量的末尾做了一个 copy_if，然后你调用了 thrust::sort，我的意思是，从技术上讲，你确实实现了一个并行归并。不完全是，我认为面试官想要的不是这个，但你知道，当然，当然。但我想说的是，从这里开始只会越来越好，我的意思是，如果你想说那个，你可能可以选择更糟的
you know i i i don't even want to uh you could have some like you know nested reductions or something like that call a call a max or you know copy it over and then do basically a hand roll a parallel insertion sort or bubble sort or whatever the heck it's called find the just repeated reductions anyways that's a You could go downhill is all I'm saying. Yeah. So continue with your idea. Well, I don't really have... My idea was only half-baked.
你知道，我甚至不想……你可以有一些，你知道，嵌套归约之类的东西，调用一个 max，或者你知道，复制过去，然后基本上手工编写一个并行插入排序或冒泡排序，或者不管它叫什么，找到重复的归约。总之，这是一个……你可以走下坡路，我只是想说。是啊。所以继续你的想法。嗯，我真的没有……我的想法只是半生不熟的。
It's like you have a copy if with some kind of like iterator sequence. Like, you know, there's the permutation iterator. And is there some way that you could get... Like if you combine the vectors, is there some way that you could construct a permutation iterator that when combined with a copy of results in that final merged sorted sequence?
就像你有一个带有某种迭代器序列的 copy_if。就像，你知道，有置换迭代器。有没有什么方法可以让你得到……就像如果你合并这些向量，有没有什么方法可以构造一个置换迭代器，当它与 copy_if 结合时，会产生最终合并后的排序序列？
So imagine you've got the lists like 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10. And then you've got another list, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10. You put those together. So now you've got one to 10 followed by one to 10. And so the permutation iterator would go from like the first element to the 11th element, then back to the second element and then to the 12th element. And it would repeat that until you got all 20 elements done. So that, that permutation iterator combined with a copy if algorithm gets you your
所以想象你有像 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 这样的列表。然后你有另一个列表，1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10。你把它们放在一起。所以现在你有一个 1 到 10，后面跟着 1 到 10。所以置换迭代器会从第一个元素到第 11 个元素，然后回到第二个元素，然后到第 12 个元素。它会重复这个过程，直到你完成所有 20 个元素。所以，那个置换迭代器结合 copy_if 算法就能得到你的
merged sequence. And a copy if is just a scan underneath the hood. The question is, is like, how do you, is it possible to construct that permutation iterator based off of, it's like, it's data dependent, right? So most permutation iterators, they follow some kind of pattern. So how are you going to construct this permutation so yeah that that's the final question is is is it even possible to construct uh it doesn't even need to be a permutation iterator there's other iterators it but it seems like the permutation iterator is the closest one to like what we want but uh how do so it described to me again how you'd construct this well i don't know i I'm only like 60% of the way. I went from 50% of the way there to being 60% of the way there.
合并序列。而 copy_if 在底层只是一个扫描。问题是，你如何……是否有可能基于它构造那个置换迭代器，它是数据相关的，对吧？所以大多数置换迭代器，它们遵循某种模式。那么你将如何构造这个置换呢？所以是的，这就是最后一个问题，是否甚至有可能构造……它甚至不需要是一个置换迭代器，还有其他的迭代器，但看起来置换迭代器是最接近我们想要的那个，但是……那么，再向我描述一遍你会如何构造这个？嗯，我不知道，我只完成了 60%。我从完成了 50% 到了完成了 60%。
Describe for me again what you want this permutation iterator to model. So if you've got two sequences of 1 to 10, you put those together in a single list. So you've got the values 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, followed by 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10. So you want your permutation iterator. I will visually show this to Bryce, but the listener cannot see this. You're at 1, and then you want to jump to the 11th element, which is also 1. And then you want to jump back to the second element, then to the 12th element, the third element, then the 13th element. And that way you when you copy if with a permutation iterator you're going to end up with one one two two three three four four five five this this sounds similar
再为我描述一遍你想要这个置换迭代器模拟什么。所以如果你有两个 1 到 10 的序列，你把它们放在一个列表中。所以你有值 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10，后面跟着 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10。所以你想要你的置换迭代器。我会向 Bryce 直观地展示这一点，但听众看不到。你在 1，然后你想跳到第 11 个元素，它也是 1。然后你想跳回第二个元素，然后到第 12 个元素，第三个元素，然后第 13 个元素。这样当你用置换迭代器进行 copy_if 时，你最终会得到 1, 1, 2, 2, 3, 3, 4, 4, 5, 5。这听起来很像
to an iterator that i wrote for thread scheduling a while back and i'm by a while back i mean like 10 years ago which i called a spiral iterator because when you, because when you're stealing from work queues in a high-performance threading system, you want to steal from the work queues that are closest to you. And so the spiral iterator would first check the queue that's one past you, and then it would check the queue one behind you, then it would check the queue two past you, then it'd check the queue two behind you. And so it would sort of checks in a spiral shape that grows outwards. This kind of reminds me of that. It's not exactly a spiral. The only reason it reminds you of that is just because the data is one to 10, and then one to 10. If the two lists were one to 10, and 11 to 20 10. If the two lists were 1 to 10 and 11 to 20,
我很久以前为线程调度写的一个迭代器，我说的很久以前是指 10 年前，我称之为螺旋迭代器，因为当你……因为当你在高性能线程系统中从工作队列中窃取任务时，你想从离你最近的工作队列中窃取。所以螺旋迭代器会首先检查你之后的一个队列，然后它会检查你之前的一个队列，然后它会检查你之后两个的队列，然后它会检查你之前两个的队列。所以它会以一种向外生长的螺旋形状进行检查。这让我想起了那个。它不完全是螺旋。它让你想起那个的唯一原因只是因为数据是 1 到 10，然后是 1 到 10。如果这两个列表是 1 到 10，和 11 到 20，
your permutation iterator should just be an iterator that goes left to right. It would still remind me of this, because you can think of it as going like, and then going, and then going. But it only reminds you of that for this data. If you change the data so that when you combine list one and list two, it's just a monotonically increase in sequence. There's no shooing back and forth.
你的置换迭代器应该只是一个从左到右的迭代器。它仍然会让我想到那个，因为你可以把它想象成这样，然后那样，然后那样。但它只对这个数据让你想起那个。如果你改变数据，使得当你合并列表一和列表二时，它只是一个单调递增的序列。没有来回穿梭。
The iterate, the permutation iterator just goes left to right. Okay, I understand. You are correct. It does do this kind of spiraling thing. The permutation iterator needs to go in the order. Okay, so the permutation iterator you're describing basically has to do the merging. Yeah. So you're asking for a magic black box.
迭代器，置换迭代器只是从左到右。好吧，我明白了。你是对的。它确实做了这种螺旋式的事情。置换迭代器需要按顺序进行。好吧，所以你描述的置换迭代器基本上必须进行归并。是啊。所以你是在要一个神奇的黑盒子。
Hey, hey, I'm not hearing any better ideas from you. I'm on three hours of sleep here. I've been up since I don't even remember when. Oh, yeah, I almost died on the plane too. That was crazy. That was oh yeah I almost died on the plane too that was crazy that was crazy you almost died on the plane yeah yeah you want would you like to elaborate yeah I would like to elaborate although my girlfriend said that I I didn't almost die but you know she's a doctor so what does she know um she says I tend to the over be overly dramatic at times. But I went to sleep on the last hour of the flight to Reykjavik from Toronto. And I slept with my head on like the pullout tray table because I'm not fancy like Bryce, you know, in first class with the kickout bed or whatever.
嘿，嘿，我没听到你有什么更好的主意。我只睡了三个小时。我不知道从什么时候起就一直醒着。哦，对了，我在飞机上还差点死了。那太疯狂了。那太疯狂了。你在飞机上差点死了？是啊，是啊。你想详细说明一下吗？是的，我想详细说明一下，尽管我女朋友说我并没有差点死，但你知道，她是医生，她懂什么？嗯，她说我有时往往过于戏剧化了。但我从多伦多飞往雷克雅未克的航班的最后一小时睡着了。我把头靠在拉出的托盘桌上睡觉，因为我不像 Bryce 那样讲究，你知道，坐在头等舱里有伸展床什么的。
And I woke up. We rarely are in first class. We usually fly in business class. Okay. Well, you know, potato. It's different. Tomato, tomato. It's just semantics. It's a callback to episode 187. Anyways, I woke up. Long story short, I had, I think, cut off some of the blood, however my neck was sleeping, to my brain. And so my brain was like extremely short of oxygen. And I felt so lightheaded. I was like, I thought I was going to be sick. And then I asked the guy if I could go to the washroom. And I got like halfway to the back of
然后我醒了。我们很少坐头等舱。我们通常坐商务舱。好吧，你知道，土豆，番茄。这只是语义问题。这是对第 187 期的回调。总之，我醒了。长话短说，我想，我的脖子睡觉的姿势切断了一些血液，流向我的大脑。所以我的大脑极度缺氧。我感到非常头晕。我当时想，我以为我要病了。然后我问那个人我能不能去洗手间。我走到飞机后部的一半，
the plane and basically like passed out. Coincidentally, like right next to a doctor. She was like, oh, this guy needs help and uh i didn't like i didn't i didn't come to and like realize what was going on for like four minutes i was if you've ever had like a head rush imagine that times a thousand like my head was so high in the clouds no pun intended i was just you're lucky they didn't divert you're lucky you didn't get a medical diversion well we were we were 30 minutes away from reykjavik and i'm not sure if you know anything about iceland but there's nowhere i think i literally said at one point i was like there's nowhere this plane could like go and at one point i started not if it had been if it had been like 30 minutes earlier you could have been
基本上就晕倒了。巧合的是，就在一位医生旁边。她说，哦，这个人需要帮助，而且我……我没有恢复意识，也没有意识到发生了什么，大约四分钟。如果你曾经有过那种头晕目眩的感觉，想象一下那感觉放大一千倍，我的头就像在云端一样，没有双关语的意思，我只是……你很幸运他们没有改航，你很幸运你没有遇到医疗改航。嗯，我们离雷克雅未克还有 30 分钟的路程，我不确定你对冰岛了解多少，但我想我当时真的说了一句，我说这架飞机没地方可去，而且有一次我开始……如果它早 30 分钟，你可能已经被
diverted to london edinburgh no that's past iceland oh this was to iceland yeah yeah you connected in iceland i understand yeah i went from i thought you're talking about going to norway yes okay yes oh yeah yeah this was the toronto to iceland like i understand and yeah once at one point i started talking about oprah because uh three sisters and a mother uh i watched a lot of oprah uh when i was in high school and there was an episode where they were trying to shed some light on this terrible thing that was happening where high school kids were basically like purposely asphyxiating they were like choking each other specifically to do to like do that
改航到伦敦、爱丁堡了，不，那是过了冰岛。哦，这是去冰岛。是啊，是啊。你在冰岛转机，我明白。是啊，我从……我以为你在说去挪威。是的，好吧，是的。哦，是的，是的，这是多伦多到冰岛的航班，我明白。是的，有一次我开始谈论奥普拉，因为……三个姐妹和一个母亲，我在高中时看了很多奥普拉的节目，有一集他们试图揭露正在发生的这件可怕的事情，高中生基本上是故意窒息，他们互相掐脖子，专门为了做那个
thing where you cut your oxygen and blood from the brain then you pass out but then when you wake up from passing out you get like the craziest head rush possible but it's extremely dangerous and a bunch of kids were dying from this and so oprah had this like special episode where she was like being like you know kind of like it was uh don't do this don't eat the tide pods of its day you know like uh don't do this really stupid thing anyways i was trying to tell the flight attendants i was like oh this is like i accidentally did what oprah was talking about that one time yeah i don't think they understood what i was saying but uh well i'm glad you didn't die buddy yeah apparently i i wasn't close to death it was
切断大脑氧气和血液的事情，然后你晕倒了，但当你从晕倒中醒来时，你会得到尽可能疯狂的头晕感，但这极其危险，一群孩子因此而死，所以奥普拉有这个特别节目，她就像是……你知道，有点像是……那是……不要这样做，不要吃那个时代的 Tide Pods，你知道，就像……不要做这种非常愚蠢的事情。总之，我当时试图告诉空乘人员，我说，哦，这就像我意外地做了奥普拉那次谈论的事情。是啊，我不认为他们听懂了我在说什么，但是……好吧，我很高兴你没死，伙计。是啊，显然我离死亡还很远，那是
i would have been fine uh well we're gonna have to uh call it here because i gotta go run a fairly important meeting um that is at 5 p.m local time so we'll see if i survive that so yeah we're gonna have to talk more about this this merge algorithm so you gotta you gotta research the thing that we do in in cub is called merge path i don't know how it worked if anybody knows how it works let us know we should just bring uh okay we should just bring you know duane on uh duane merrill get him to explain it to us that's not a bad idea not a bad idea at all do you want to do that we work i mean he's on my team we could pretty easily reach out to him be like hey duane yeah we'll just trick him we'll say we'll say uh hey we want to talk about, and he'll be here in a heartbeat. I think he'd be equally excited about sorts and merging.
我会没事的。好吧，我们得在这里结束了，因为我得去参加一个相当重要的会议，那是当地时间下午 5 点，所以我们看看我能不能挺过去。所以是的，我们得更多地谈谈这个归并算法。所以你得研究一下我们在 CUB 中所做的东西，叫归并路径。我不知道它是怎么工作的，如果有人知道它是怎么工作的，请告诉我们。我们应该直接把……好吧，我们应该直接把 Dwayne 请来，Dwayne Merrill，让他给我们解释一下。这主意不错，一点也不坏。你想那样做吗？我们工作……我的意思是，他是我的团队成员，我们可以很容易地联系他，说嘿 Dwayne，是的，我们会骗他，我们会说嘿，我们想谈谈，他会立刻赶来的。我想他会对排序和归并同样感到兴奋。
All right. I got to run. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed, and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast.
好吧。我得走了。一定要在你的播客应用程序或 ADSPthepodcast.com 上查看这些节目笔记，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的口号。
It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那不是口号。我们的口号是充满信息碎片的混乱。这一期还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。